[Musique]
bonjour yasmine belmadi vous êtes
conseiller régional ile-de-france nous
allons ouvrir ce café politique en
essayant de mieux vous connaître mais
tout d'abord en parlant aussi de
l'actualité parce que vous étiez élu
front national et vous avez décidé de
quitter ce groupe à la région pour vous
rapprocher plutôt d'un mouvement
peut-être vous allez nous dire lancé par
nicolas dupont aignan et jean frédéric
poisson
pourquoi quitter déjà ce groupe front
national à la région donc beau le jour
wilfrid donc effectivement j'ai quitté
le groupe
c'est un front national au la région
ile-de-france
pour plusieurs raisons pas seulement
régionale mais
globale au niveau national départemental
et régional aussi en matière de gestion
humaine de prises de position politiques
on l'a vu dernièrement
avec le débat de l'entre-deux tours
c'est vrai que ça suscite est un peu de
trouble vis-à-vis des militants des
sympathisants
on peut dire qu'un débat ça peut se
rater c'est dommage mais c'est comme ça
mais c'est vrai que depuis depuis ce
débat est même déjà avant on avait une
certaine
instabilité au niveau des prises de
positions sur certains sujets et ça
s'est accentué depuis ce débat et puis
les législatives qui ont suivi puis
l'impréparation pour les sénatoriales
contenir donc voilà je ne me sentais
plus à l'aise dans ce groupe pour pour
continuer à défendre les valeurs qui ont
fait et des idées qui ont fait que je me
suis engagé au front national et que
j'ai porté les couleurs du front
national à de multiples reprises et qui
ont fait mon élection au conseil
régional vous trouvez que le front
national aujourd'hui penche trop à
gauche oui effectivement alors
effectivement on pourrait se dire que
non puisque les discours depuis le
départ de florent philippot sont plutôt
à droite mais pour moi
on a de nombreux signes
intérieurs comme extérieurs qui qui
montre qu'en fait finalement c'est ce
sont des postures et finalement au front
national reste à gauche en fait
pour moi tant qu'il y avait un certain
équilibre entre marion maréchal-le pen
et florian philippot qui était assurée
par marine le pen et 20 c'était super
tout le monde était content
effectivement j'avais un peu plus de
sensibilité vers marion mais le combat a
été le même pour tous et c'est marine
qui portaient très bien cette synthèse
des deux sensibilités
petit à petit le déséquilibre s'est
accentuée et beaucoup de départs au
niveau national
et on a bien eu le départ de florian
philippot mais finalement les fins
florian philippot n'étais pas seul dans
la décision avec mon politique du front
national donc je trouve ça un peu facile
de le critiquer
celui ci alors qu'on garde finalement
les mêmes personnes pareil on parle de
refondation bomba personnellement je
suis sceptique après mon objectif c'est
pas c'est pas de dénigrer le front
national je suis contente d'avoir fait
un bout de chemin j'ai rencontré des
personnes formidables
et maintenant je voudrais effectivement
évolué un peu plus
pour une sorte d'ouverture à droite mais
alors oui on parle de mouvement lancé
par nicolas dupont aignan qui s'appelle
les amoureux de la france voici jean
frédéric poisson qui avait été candidat
à la primaire de la droite et qui est un
ancien député des yvelines oui alors
pour l'instant là je prends mon temps je
viens de quitter un groupe dans lequel
j'ai fait un parcours assez long
et je prends le temps de de poser les
choses parce que il s'agit pas d'agir
dans la précipitation et s'agit pas non
plus de quitter pour rallier tout de
suite quelqu'un ou me mettre sous la
halle de quelqu'un nous ce qu'on veut
c'est dialoguer avec tout le monde feint
faire que nos valeurs soient le plus
forte possible et est vrai pour la
france et que vous les français pas la
seule à avoir quitté le groupe front
national à la région vous êtes 3,3 et
lui avoir décidé de 2 alors est-ce que
c'est mettre en parenthèse justement ont
claqué la porte parce que le front
national vous pourriez retourner ou pas
du tout ouh la la cassure est vraiment
je pourrais continuer à dialoguer avec
le front national mais il retourne et
non
c'est clair ça va être c'est clair c'est
net dans ma tête je regrette pas mon
choix je suis voilà je
j'avais des désaccords à la fois sur des
méthodes et sur la ligne politique
ça n'empêche qu'il ya des gens
formidables et que pour ma part je pense
que le jeu serait plus utile enfin je me
semble plus utile en dehors pour
continuer à
défendre mes valeurs au cours de cette
émission nous revenons principalement
sur le parcours politique des élus
gemalto j'aimerais qu'on prenne le temps
par don de parler de vous vous avez 35
ans vous êtes d'origine marocaine
pourquoi avoir rejoint le front national
alors je suis d'origine marocaine et
espagnole mais peu importe avant tout je
suis française en fait j'ai la chance
d'avoir grandi et d'avoir fait mes
études dans un beau pays d'avoir donné
la vie aussi être à trois beaux enfants
c'est la mère qui parle
et et au delà de juste profiter du
confort et de la sécurité qu'apporte ce
pays j'ai envie de pouvoir le
transmettre à mes enfants et plutôt que
de rester et aux générations à venir
aussi bien sûr plutôt que de rester
passives et de regarder dans mon coin ce
qui me semble être des échecs politiques
pour la france depuis des années j'ai
choisi de rejoindre le front national
qui effectivement n'est pas le choix le
plus conformiste mais justement ça ça me
semblait être le choix le plus juste
pour défendre la france les valeurs de
la famille également la méritocratie et
puis un certain équilibre entre
comme on ne parlait d' état stratège
c'est à dire que l'état qui sert de
tremplin ou un peu aux plus faibles pas
qu'il est qu'il est qu'aucun fin qui
leur donne tout servi sur un plateau
mais voilà
quelqu'un qui est qui sert à promouvoir
à aider face face à la concurrence très
forte des grands groupes et et maintenir
un tissu social donc voilà j'ai rejoint
j'ai adhéré en 2011 au front national et
j'ai commencé à m'impliquer pendant la
campagne des municipales en 2014 à
vélizy vous parlez de la famille tout à
l'heure comment votre famille l'a perçu
cet engagement je reprécise au front
national parce que oui ce n'est pas
anodin finalement comme à ben c'est sûr
que le choix a surpris et des routes et
quelques membres de ma famille après
j'ai expliqué mes choix et finalement
une fois que c'est argumenté et qu' il
voit enfin j'ai bien vu de l'intérieur
que on est bien loin des stéréotypes
dont on a une image à l'extérieur
j'avais l'image aussi des dérapages de
jean marie le pen par exemple ça ne vous
a pas effrayés au moment de rejoindre le
front national en fait j'ai rejoint en
2011 donc c'était déjà marine le pen qui
était qui avait pris les rênes du parti
oui il ya des dérapages mais il y en a
dans tous les partis de toutes façons et
et et je les condamne mais le combat
enfin le combat ça fait très très
agressif hardyson la défense de nos
valeurs il faut il faut savoir dépasser
un peu nos différences et aller au delà
dans le sens bien sûr pas à
contre-courant des idées non plus alors
vous déplorez la décroissance de la
france un laxisme judiciaire une
immigration non contrôlée on ne sait
plus qui rentrent qui sort c'est ce que
vous dites un système éducatif niveler
par le bas c'est ce que j'ai lu sur les
différentes interviews en préparant cet
échange pour vous aujourd'hui et avec
l'élection des mad men macro est ce que
les choses ont un peu évolué
alors c'est vrai que les annonces de
monsieur blanquer sont plutôt saluer
enfin comment dire est salutaire
on attend bien sûr de voir la
concrétisation mais c'est déjà un pas
par rapport à ce qui était fait dans les
précédents gouvernements
pour ce qui est du travail de la santé
la sécurité pour l'éducation visiblement
ça a l'air d'aller dans le bon sens et
tant mieux 1 je suis pas là pour si le
ciel est bleu je vais pas dire que le
sait les noirs parce que ces manuels mc
ren qu'il l'a dit un par contre on reste
vigilant parce que effectivement sur la
loi de travail etc on ne partage pas
tout à fait la même la même vision donc
plutôt que juste critiquer nos seins moi
ce que je veux et puis mes collègues qui
ont quitté le groupe avec moi ce qu'on
veut c'est vraiment essayé de
permettre le dialogue et puis d'aller
dans le sens effectivement il ya
l'initiative des amoureux de la france
il n'y a pas que les amoureux de la
france et pourquoi pas l'objectif n'est
pas de multiplier les paroisses c'est
vraiment d'essayer de s'unir tous
ensemble et est d'être à l'écouté de
tous pour aller vraiment dans le bon
sens quoi parce que tout le monde veut
aller dans le bon dans le on est
plusieurs à vouloir aller dans le même
sens mais chacun a son parti chacun à sa
paroisse et du coup finalement on est
inaudible et ou au niveau des élections
pèse on pèse rien donc à l'avenir
politique pour vous le voyez comment
justement vous avez été candidate aux
législatives aussi donc vous êtes élue à
la région vous projeter sur le prochain
mandat les prochains combats alors pour
les municipales j'espère pouvoir
constituer une liste
de tous les bons toutes les bonnes
volontés pour la ville de vélizy après
ma foi pour le reste oui bien sûr si
j'ai la possibilité de continuer à
défendre dans un mandat régional ou dans
un autre mandat mes valeurs et mes idées
je le ferai mais pour moi la politique
n'est pas une fin en soi c'est un moyen
de porter nos idées après en même temps
que mon mandat d'élu régional
je conserve une activité professionnelle
et ça me permet de on va dire garder la
tête froide et les pieds sur terre et
donc si ma foi ma carrière politique
s'arrête à la fin de mon mandat régional
et bien je reprendrai une vie privée et
puis est serré quand même de peser à
travers des associations je ne sais quoi
vous arrivez à conjuguer les deux vie
professionnelle et la vie politique
alors je vous êtes cadre analystes
financiers c'est ça exactement donc
c'est un planning très chargé ça demande
beaucoup d'organisation d'autant que
j'ai trois jeunes enfants également mais
c'est cette motivation et puis c'est
justement ces enfants qui qui me donne
cette énergie pour pour pour combiner
tout ça on va arriver à la fin de cette
émission le même questionnaire que pour
tous les élus qui viennent ici votre
livre de chevet
petite histoire de france le dernier
film que vous ayez vu
votre film préféré peut-être est la vie
est belle et dernière question votre
style musical peut-être préféré alors
j'aime bien la variété française les
années 80 c'est vrai que c'est une
période où on avait énormément de deux
choix c'est une période qui a marqué qui
réunit toutes les générations
puisqu'on parle musique justement une
dernière question la présidente du front
national qui s'est vu interdire l'accès
aux obsèques par la famille de johnny
hallyday ça vous a choqué
à la fois
je trouve que dans 2 le communiqué comme
ça que ce soit de la part de la famille
ou la part de marine le pen oui c'est
regrettable se trouvent parce que c'est
un événement qui touche toute la france
et tous les français et qu'on interdise
comme ça
je trouve ça pas très glorifiant et je
trouve ça un peu de l'intercom
l'instrumentalisation politique après ma
foi si c'est le choix de la famille
je ne peux pas aller à l'encontre est
d'ailleurs marine le pen à respecter ce
choix tout en
regrettant qu' on la refuse de cette
manière merci m nl matt conseillère
régionale d'île de france d'avoir
participé au café politique
[Musique]